وجودي معكم احلى من استلام اجري بمليون
مره بهذه الكلمات توجه هاني شاكر الى
الجمهور الحاضر في حفلته الاخيره والتي
عرضت في البحرين اثناء عيد الفطر
بعد ان تعرض الفنان المصري لنصب بعد هروب
المتعهد دون دفع اجور الفنان وفرقته ورغم
هذه الظروف الصعبه التي يعتذر فيها
الكثيرون الا ان هاني شاكر قرر الغناء
للجمهور الحاضر حيث خاطب الجمهور في بدايه
الحفل قائلا احترم وجودكم معي جدا بالرغم
من الظروف الغريبه التي حصلت لي وفرقتي في
هذه الحفله وهروب المتعهد وعدم التزامه
بالدفع وللفرقه اجرنا لكن ان وجودي معكم
احلى من استلام اجري بمليون مره وسطه
هتافات وتصفيق الجمهور المحب لهاني شاكر
احترم وجودكم معايا النهارده جدا جدا
الظروف الغريبه اللي حصلت لي في الحفله دي
انا وفرح وهروب المتعهد وعلى الحزام علينا
اجر الفرقه اجري لكن انا وجودي معكم احلى
من اجري مليون مره
المتعهد الهارب في اللحظات الاخيره لم
يدفع ايضا مستحقات الفندق الذي استضاف
الحفل بحسب ما غردت الاعلاميه الكويتيه
فجر السعيد التي نشرت على مواقع التواصل
صوره جواز سفر المتعهد واكدت انها حجزت 20
تذكره للحفله واستطاعت استرداد ثمنها من
شريك المتعهد مطالبه نزاله الداخليه
البحرينيه بالتحقيق في الواقعه